[Music]
I see myself as an Aztec and I carry the
roots of my culture within me I've
worked in farming since I was a boy my
grandparents once grew vegetables such
as letters on this land today the work
is done by my father my brother and me a
silas paddling to his chin imper part of
a sustainable farming system established
by his aztec forefathers 500 years ago
chinampas are artificial islands made
from mud and reeds and separated by
canals they're typically 300 meters long
and 15 meters wide to this day farming
is done by hand with no help from
tractors or plows we use buckets to take
the water and the mud that we need
straight from the canals then we
transport it all in our boats to drying
out the mud we plant the seeds in the
resulting soil it's a technique used
centuries ago by our ancestors the
Aztecs and it's very efficient youth on
if he's hostile harvests the produce
from his channel per up to 5 times a
year he sells the vegetables to
restaurants in downtown Mexico City the
historic Center is just 20 kilometres
away the chinampas are one of the last
remaining oases in the sprawling mega
city 500 kilometers away on the coast of
the Gulf of Mexico floor are honest Cruz
is hoping to numbers will make her life
easier empty again she catches fish and
craps for a living but today's catch is
modest she set up 20 traps which have
ensnared just eight crabs there used to
be a lot more crabs here at this time of
year there'd already be really big ones
but there was nothing today normally
we'd have more crabs when the current
comes but that's not the case we're
really noticing the change for the crabs
finding refuge along the coast is
becoming increasingly difficult due to
deforestation mangroves have suffered
especially heavy losses
and have been depleted by over 30% over
the past 40 years
that means the disappearance of a
crucial protective habitat for local
animals
these people are determined to revive
those havens in a regional mangrove
planting scheme nobody here is bothered
about getting their fingers dirty it's
actually kind of fun the men are
building chinampas just as the Aztecs
did five hundred years ago the little
islands of earth and reeds will provide
homes for the mangroves to thrive in
we're using the technique because the
land is so deep in the water the plant
wouldn't grow without the support of the
chinampa it would be blown over by the
first gust of wind the mangrove
reforestation scheme is organized by
Sittler Leal Haley
and her team from the pronator a
conservation group they initially had
difficulty reintroducing mangroves in
the coastal regions they wouldn't grow
because the water level was too high
it's surprising to see this old chinampa
technique from central Mexico one that's
being used here on the Gulf to help
replenish mangroves it's great to be
creating a link to our heritage and also
that people from the region are involved
in the project
mangroves used to be everywhere here but
they've now been replaced by pastureland
right up to the shore grazed by cattle
in a traditional fishing region flora
are honest crews and her family are
pinning their hopes on the conservation
group and the chinampas once the
mangrove forests have been restored
their haul of fish and crabs should grow
again as well Fleur and her husband and
son took part in the planting project
helping to re-establish the old
ecosystem I was practically born in the
water in the river I never went to
school one of the few things I do know
about the world is how important the
mangroves are for us and the entire
system for all the species for everyone
and everything
back in the center of the country the
suburbs of the capital have been
creeping ever closer to the chinampas in
recent years assail and the other
farmers are concerned about their fields
the biggest danger for this old method
of sustainable farming is humankind
itself when the piece alambre wherever
people go they pollute they leave trash
everywhere including in the canals
eventually they fill up and dry out and
you can't row down them anymore
the canals become dirty would like to
see his children take over his chin
hamper one day passing on a piece of
their Aztec heritage
you